twitter and square ceo jack dorsey says
hyperinflation will happen soon in the
u.s and the world now hyperinflation for
people that don't know kai
it's two two months in or fifty percent
yeah it's what's 50 increase month over
month yeah but but that's what the
scholars have put it that doesn't
necessarily have to be the case no
hyperinflation could be 10 15 but the
scholar said categorically it's 50 so
they just kind of came up with this
number and we followed that guideline
but here's what happened this is a cnbc
story uh twitter co-founder jack dorsey
weighed in on escalating inflation in
the u.s saying things are going to get
considerably worse hyperinflation is
going to change everything dorsey
tweeted it's happening he added that he
sees the inflation problem escalating
around the globe it will happen in the
u.s soon and so the world the tweet
comes with consumer price inflation
running near a 30-year high in the us
and grown concern that the problem work
could be worse than policy makers have
anticipated it's one thing to call for a
faster inflation but it may be
surprising to some that dorsey used the
word hyper inflation condition of
rapidly rising prices that can ruin
currencies and bring down whole economy
so i'm going to go to you first with
this one before i go to tyler and kai
well i think for sure no matter what
jack dorsey says on twitter i don't
think he's going to get removed or
cancelled from twitter that's a good
point i think no matter what he says
he's going to love research
he's going to be okay
adam real quick how did you get to that
conclusion yeah i think you know he he
knows that uh people are two on twitter
but i know you brushed over the numbers
but i actually thought you'd be a little
bit more um i'm reading the story first
and then we can meaning like you're a
numbers guy yeah and inflation typically
runs at what two to three percent year
over year two percent is a good level
okay right so social security was just
adjusted for our senior seniors we have
a large senior community well you know
this is our podcast
um it was just adjusted believe it or
not you're not joking yeah we have
actually a big senior community what as
crazy as it sounds yeah i got stopped by
78 year old at the beach saying hey you
know i listen to every single podcast
you guys do and and not only that she's
a 78 year old jewish grandma that's
awesome she said you're the only podcast
i listened to it happens to be my
grandma
your grandpa whatever bro
um but the reality is they just got a uh
i don't even call it a pay raise a
retirement raise of 5.9
right there's no secret that inflation's
definitely gone up they're saying that
it's somewhere around five six percent
they're saying that it's transitory
maybe it's not transitory but i think
when you use the word hyper inflation
yeah so if you're using if you're
typically running it two to three
percent and there was just a adjustment
cost of living at five six percent and
now you're talking
the definition of inflation is fifty
percent a month or a thousand percent a
year yeah high priority we're not a
hyperinflation it's not even close so is
it hyperbolic
she can uh so that's a religion right
whether you're gonna agree with her
because she talked about the fact that
in 2008 she believed hyperinflation was
coming because the whole uh alan
greenspan uh you know quantitative
easing that she did she said i ended up
being wrong yeah she walked that back
yeah so
um she's the opposite end of michael
berry just remember that so she's the
opposite of birth she's whatever berry
believes she's the complete opposition
baris shorts tesla she longs tesla so
you just gotta know they're big on
somehow they're both very successful
investors they're both very successful
but they're very opposite religions i
just want you to know she's doing okay
with tesla right now i'm not i'm not
saying i'm just saying those are two
opposites so if you're a bury camp she's
the opposite the the point that i'm
ultimate getting at is is inflation here
yes is inflation real yes is
hyperinflation here yet there's no
indication that that's here yet this is
all speculation this is him being
hyperbolic yeah and he's not going to
get canceled for saying stuff like this
when was the last time you know that
that in united states we had
hyper inflation
hyper inflation
from what i understand it hasn't
happened since the frickin civil war
right there's only been hyper inflation
cases in world history so it's very rare
okay i mean look at what's going on in
venezuela right now you think that's
hyperinflation right i think that's
happening here i don't think so but but
here's the question are you saying it's
not possible anything's possible okay so
anything's possible but but what you're
saying is that it's not gonna happen
this time around i just i just so so why
don't you unpack why you don't think it
can happen this time around
you seem very certain about it i like it
i like your certificate because i don't
want hyperinflation i want to lean on
your confidence educate the rest of us
why i don't want it either to be clear
but when you have economists weighing in
got it and they're basically saying hey
jack dorsey yeah stick to your long
beards and tweeting go back to smoking a
pie all that stuff i saw this we'll take
it from here yeah so
i want you to go deeper homeboy i want
you to go
i want you to go
and actually think about it let's
actually go there let's actually talk
about it okay so why don't we think it's
because half the battle would ever this
is what i can you put that tweet i just
text you right now with uh dorsey i said
the this is dorsey's tweet
hyperinflation is going to change
everything it's happening i said you
have two groups here number one many
entrepreneurs and operators who say
hyperinflation is coming number two many
scholars and professors who say it's not
one is in the game the other studies the
game who's right we're gonna find out
okay because you've got two guys one is
the professors it'll never happen the
economist it'll never happen
dorsey's in it runs square gets every
data probably has more access to data
than anybody else in the world to find
out the transactions and the 10
different things that they offer there
with their you know credit services with
their you know payments they can find
out who's buying what at what point they
can see everything no one has more
there's probably only
a handful there's probably only 20
people that have access to that kind of
data as he does okay it's probably going
to be jamie diamond it's probably going
to be stripe it's going to be some of
those guys some of them it's not a guy
that's saying something like this that
woke up one day smoke some hash and it's
like hey hyperinflation is coming he
doesn't also seem like somebody who has
wild predictions and just throws things
out there kind of
about stuff like that normally anyways
don't forget that's the same guy that
also permanently banned trump so you
have to know that obviously you can't
say this guys so so you have to know
where his processing comes from but
hyperinflation i want us to go deeper
look why don't we think it'll happen
this time i don't i'm not saying that i
don't think it will happen i'm just
giving some numbers out there what
actual inflation is where the adjusted
cost of living is for seniors right now
and the
benchmarks that you have to reach to
reach hyperinflation again hyperinflate
high inflation is here no doubt we
printed 40 percent of the world's of
united states money in the last 18
months we printed what five trillion
dollars that's no freaking joke i'm not
downplaying that what so ever right but
have we hit fifty percent a month and we
had a thousand percent a year we haven't
hit that yet what if we've hit a tipping
point where that's where we're headed
that's the question that's what i'm
concerned hang on hyperinflation by
whose standards does does jack dorsey
mean hyperinflation at 50 month over
month a thousand percent a year or does
he just is he being a little bit
hyperbolic but 10 inflation it's not
hyperinflation but you definitely feel
it it hurts it's going to hurt the
economy it's going to blow so
hyperinflation by whose standards okay
yeah so then use the word high inflation
but to use hyperinflation like we're
using definitions right here right right
hey definitely uh hi inflation's here
bro brace yourself okay cool i got it by
the way to say hyperinflation make a
good point because the morgan stanley
cio came out yesterday i don't know if
you guys saw this right now morgan
stanley ciao came out and they asked him
saying hey what do you think about the
fact that dorsey said you know
hyperinflation or stagflation he says
those are you can't use those words he
says we're not going to use those words
what we do believe is inflation is here
and it ain't going away anytime soon so
he didn't say what yellen said three
months ago which is it's just like
temporary it's gonna go away or what
biden said at the cnn town hall when he
said you know probably in the first or
second quarter of 2022 it's going to go
away you know gas prices are going to go
back down to what it is and then the guy
asked and says so some of the issues and
he wanted to border which we'll get into
that later on but morgan stanley cio
agrees with you they don't think
hyperinflation is coming all i'm asking
for is indicators to make us believe
that that's not going to happen because
what is the cause of inflation what
causes inflation printing of money okay
what a money supply what else is it two
months it's a supply and demand thing
it's a supply and demand thing what else
is it
um
workforce workforce what else is it well
i would say the cost of goods obviously
smp
all-time highs is
a big uh say that again s p and dow hit
all-time highs yesterday it's like why
why did they do that no there's no
access properties access to goods a
bunch of stuff that are financed
fake success yeah credit credits debt
all of that stuff right that's that's
causing hyperinflation now i'm going to
regenerate yelling because before we
continue with this here's what janet
yellen had to say about inflation just
yesterday or two days ago yellen says
americans have experienced current
inflation rate in a long time haven't
experienced current inflation rates in a
long time a cnbc story many firms are
experiencing a shortage of uh labor
yellen says during an interview with cnn
sunday the coveted shock to the economy
has caused disruptions that will be
working through over the next year
and of course americans haven't seen
inflation like we've experienced in a
long time host jake tapper
noted how inflation is growing at its
fastest pace in 30 years and ask whether
spending more money on biden's build
back better agenda will be pouring gas
on inflation fire prompting yellen to
say the spending on the bipartisan
infrastructure package and a massive
social spending package would be spread
out over the next decade tapper later
asked yellen when she expects the
inflation rate to return to two percent
levels which the federal reserve
classifies as acceptable she replied i
expect improvement by the middle of next
year
second half of uh uh next year is what
she's saying okay that that's her words
let me see if there's anything else
that's it okay i have two questions go
for it
question number one do you believe her
do i believe her what's she saying
absolutely not and question number two
do you believe that she believes what
she's saying uh
uh i actually think she does okay i
actually think she does because
uh i and this is a smart woman this is
not a person that hasn't been around
she's a small boy she's been done yeah
fair share i actually think she does and
i actually think a part of it is what
you're supposed to do to make the world
not panic and overreact because the last
thing they want is for people to stop
buying for people people to stop
spending for hoarding going back into
that mode no that is not a thing she
wants for the economy because that's not
her job now i called goldman sachs
yesterday
just to kind of find out what their
thoughts on what's going on i said so
what do you think is going to happen
with rates he says well powell's already
said they're going up i said okay uh uh
what do you think is going to happen
with inflation it says it's here it's
not going away and to control inflation
the way you do it is by increasing the
rates right so yes
say say hyperinflation goes okay you go
study jimmy carter today i did video
talking about is uh
is jimmy it's joe biden
jimmy carter 2.0 or much worse right and
we compared how many markers 10 markers
on how inflation was how misery index
was and we compared from the beginning
of his administration to the time he
ended and we compared biden from the day
he got started to where it is today so
it's a very interesting thing
inflation during uh uh jimmy carter do
you know how i got
nearly 14 percent yeah okay during jimmy
carter interest rates were double digits
cds you could get a 16 cd talk about
save that money yeah 16 cd but it means
nothing if you're making 16 cd and
inflation is 14 percent you're only
going your mortgage is twelve percent
that means nothing so
here's
why
hyperinflation may not show up
this is when i when they say
hyperinflation may not show up here's
here's how i pronounce fashion i show up
hyper inflation may not show up but 10
15
interest rates may
before hyperinflation shows up they will
control it by banking interest rates 10
to 15 percent slamming the brakes
slamming the brakes at the highest level
listen pump the brakes don't go finance
anymore anymore if you can't afford a
million dollar home and you can't put 20
down guess what this ain't for you okay
no more five percent no more 10 percent
none of this stuff just go back and buy
500 000 house and come back three years
later easy money no free money the whole
fake money the easy money stuff because
money is so freaking cheap right now
it's ridiculous there is no charge there
is a part of you
correct me if i'm wrong because with all
the printing and the fake success
because you get worked up about this
there is a part of you that definitely
wants to see some things crumble some
things crash why would i want it though
tell me why i would want it because you
tell me how you actually made your
success the right way yeah so when you
see fake success you're like this but
let me ask you a question let me ask you
a question so why would i want it unpack
why would want it
why would you want why would i want that
to happen
just so reality comes back to normal i
think i mean you see a story out there
that you put a hundred dollars into
shibu inu some crypto coin now you're
worth a million bucks yeah something
ridiculous okay it's just so far-fetched
it's fake success it's fake money if you
made it the real way why would you want
fake the only the only time
where you would want something like this
to happen is sometimes we have to be
reminded
by reality hitting us yeah and it hasn't
hit america yet i also think it's a
restructuring
of the people who can and know how to do
it versus that's one area but to me to
me sometimes
look we can sit here and philosophically
talk about 93 keys to success and how to
do this with money and how to do that
with money
sometimes it's simplicity man it forces
you to go back to simple concepts this
is not about quantitative easing or qe
you know qovs or don't spend more than
you have
it just goes back to basics so america
needs to be humbled a little bit by the
economy and the way we're going right
now people are thinking this is going to
last forever we had a guy who we were
working at valleys we both leave valleys
i go to the insurance industry within
three years in the insurance industry
i'm barely making six figures a year
within three years in a mortgage
industry is making 500k
per month wow we go to their month per
month i can i go to the bank
and i'm fighting b of a on a fee he's
two uh what do you call it uh uh
he's saying i'd like to deposit 1.3
million dollars
and i look at him i'm like
he looks at me says hey pat
that's my mother he just deposited 1.3
million just give me the points 3 0 you
know 30k what year is this this is the
2004 2000 the 2000 uh 2005. first and
he's in the mortgage industry he's in a
mortgage
he's making 500k a month you know what
jake you know what happened to that guy
you know he had four rolls-royces parked
outside
you know he says i need four different
color for rolls-royces living in all the
everything was financed guess what
happened you lost it all tax every
single thing yeah wiped out because that
was fake success
and fake success gets filtered out very
very quickly and it's gonna happen again
but the direction we're going right now
when a jack dorsey says something like
this
and people say that'll never happen the
only reason i agree that hyperinflation
will never happen is because before
hyperinflation comes you're going to
experience 10 15 percent you'll see
there'll be 10 15 interesting there's
also something to be said about there's
so many people
that are
getting money or making money without
working right and here's my
let me just finish this and i'll go to
you
there's what happened to just hard work
in america i'm working my ass off i'm
working hard i'm working smart and these
i'm reaping the benefits of what i sow
now it's stimulus checks right just
unemployment it's crypto it's nft it's
whatever stock market it's my house just
appreciated 35
it's cash all cash buyers it seems a
little too good to be true and when it
is it usually is it usually is but but
adam you know
that's what 80 million people voted for
oh you're going to make this political
now but that is what 80 million people
voted for how so he explained his tax
plan
he explained to build it back better but
this happened none of that had to do
with taxes though none of that what i
just said what doesn't have to do with
taxes unemployment the stimulus
way
way way way trump gave just as much
money as biden stop this doesn't have to
do with stimulus this doesn't have to do
it no it does but not taxes trump gave
stimulus when the entire country was
locked down you couldn't do [ __ ] too
stimulus you couldn't do anything nobody
could go to work i understand do you
remember in dallas we'd walk we drive
the streets we're like [ __ ] are we going
to say we're on essentially
remember i remember when i was worried
i'd have to have like a past basically
so
i'm going to work don't arrest me do you
remember that yes we would drive the
streets worried because all of the
freeways were empty nothing i did a
story one time i'm like look at this
this doesn't make any sense
in rush hour april or when this is when
it
we came every day to work we came seven
days a week to work it was during that
time but it was well so yes
the point is that is a different era but
if you continue like this here's what
will happen i'm with you let me explain
no i know you're with me but this is
what people voted for the people that
voted for biden are getting exactly what
they voted for this is what they wanted
so you have to understand that when when
congressmen and senators
get up and they say i'm working for my
constituents you know when they say
things like that like you know they give
a mansion a hard time a mansion says
listen do you know where i live
do you know
america
but you know he just talked about the
other day he's thinking about leaving
the party i don't know if you read that
article or not the mansion is living
apart can you pull out that article
about the fact that manchester wants to
leave the party but i'm gonna give you
the story here denver's airport held the
job fair
to plug its huge labor shortage
david i think your mic is on
to plug it's huge labor shortage and
exec said
he'd hoped 5000 people would come but
only a hundred people showed up to the
job fair okay a hundred people let me
read the story too and we'll go to what
you're trying to pull up here
so five thousand people that are
expecting 100 people show up to the job
fair
um
dennis uh deslon this long champ the
president denver uh connoisseurs
association said that the organization
organizers had hoped for 5 000 people to
show up to the job fair which he called
a very lofty goal organizers had wanted
to fill out about a thousand jobs at the
airport but only 100 people came to the
four hour fair the airport's labor
shortage could be contributing to huge
airport security lines as travel
rebounds the airport also
hasn't been able to fully reopen its
shuttle bus that varies travelers to the
airport because of the shortage drivers
at its shuttle bus contractor so what's
the point here even if the jobs are out
there people are not
wanting the job because i don't need to
go back to work i'm chilling getting
unemployment what happens when the
people you've talked about this a few
times on the podcast from the people
that are making 18 an hour to flip a
burger the restaurant workers you know
the minimum wage jobs that are making 20
bucks an hour what happens when they're
either replaced or their wages drop
substantially right and on top of that
when we pump the two million dollars for
the budget bill and the three and a half
yeah
excuse me two trillion and the one and a
half trillion for the infrastructure
bill when that all comes through what
happens when the wages drop or they're
replaced by kiosks the mcdonald's
workers the burger king workers you know
the the the people that are replaceable
by machines and the truck drivers et
cetera et cetera et cetera what happens
when they're all replaced
or the wages ubi baby
are you are you asking us yeah yeah i
mean what what happened or are you
asking this
does this know what happened does this
attribute to the inflation and to
like kai said a point of no return where
we could hit inflation that's
unstoppable maybe not hyperinflation but
maybe 25 30 35 percent listen there's a
there's a community in politics
like yellen who hate billionaires
they passionately hate
billionaires they hate the fact that
these people have that much money they
hate the fact that bazel what's it
called musk is worth 200 and whatever
billion dollars nearly 300 billion
dollars they hate that a guy is that
successful they cannot stand it so
yellen says is the story here with
yellen and uh unrealized gains or no i
thought that story
by the way let me let me give you one
little i don't see the page nine it's
it's uh go ahead i'm listening just
before we move on to the talking about
there it is we're talking about the job
fair you know you know this is just a
little quick case example you talked
about minimum wage fifteen dollars or
eighteen dollars an hour twenty dollars
you know i went to i went driving
through taco bell the other day you
remember when i was out here eating my
taco bell is i think friday
there's as i'm in la i never go to taco
bell by the way um
there's a there's a for uh help wanted
you know how much they were um saying
for you know employee x and for
assistant manager x do you know how much
they were uh offering take a guess 23.
okay go ahead
yeah that's what i get yeah yeah yeah
would you say 45 grand or 50 grand a
year for for the lower end this is why
these are just workers at taco bell
workers 20 bucks an hour okay how about
i i i had to like do a double take eight
dollars an hour for an employee and 10
for an assistant manager
those were the numbers i i i go
what
this is in florida in boca raton
deerfield i go who the hell is going to
apply for who wants this job
you're hearing people that you can go to
taco bell right now take a picture of
this site
it's right there so do you think they're
worth more than that i'm just saying you
paid 15 bucks an hour i'm not saying
that i'm just saying if you're the
employee's perspective we talked about
this story being
you know 100 people shout out to a 5 000
and we talk about expectations versus
reality they're selecting 5 000 people
100 people show up
if those are the actually numbers we
talked about the fight for 15 15 minimum
wage that was actually on the sign in
front of ordering the taco bell i'm
thinking no freaking way is anyone
taking this job at this point so now
it's no wonder
all right
that they're not
taking these jobs because you could sit
home and make
triple that unemployment yeah
but but at the same i i know what you're
saying but the taco bell is owned by yum
brands
yum brands and you you have to look at
the ebitda i mean the ebitda margins
where they are if the ebitda margins are
above twenty percent and they're only
willing to pay eight to ten bucks i mean
you gotta increase your the hour you're
paying it's a mathematical formula
they're sitting there saying what they
can afford to pay they're showing
margins to the guy that's buying the
taco bell so if you end up doing 15
bucks an hour you're not selling a 50
steak you're not selling a 20 steak
you're selling a two dollar
tacos what you're selling how much
margins do they have but the person
that's gonna take that job for eight ten
twelve dollars an hour sixteen year old
kid they can't
spell ebitda they're not worried about
ebay they're like should i take this job
or not i'm not telling the kid to worry
about it
the kid doesn't need to worry about that
but the guy running the business does
because the number one goal of a
business is to what
in business you have to stay in business
if you don't stay in business then what
do you do you got to stay in business so
what do you expect the guy to do to go
out of business no but i agree with you
where they have to restructure so to me
you're you're cornering me the taco bell
owner to make the tacos price from 199
to 249. it's interesting
no problem but but watch this what's 199
to 249 how big of an increase is it it's
50 cents it's 50 cents which is what 25
yeah what's 25 percent increase on eight
dollars
it's only 10 so it's not like they're
going to go 50. so watch this to go from
8 to 15 is a 90 increase right so that
means my buck 99 taco has got to be 379.
yeah that better get a chalupa for that
price so but 379 is a taco chalupa is
what how much is a chalupa i don't know
well you look like you know what the
price of chalupa is i assume it's three
bucks four bucks okay if it's if you're
four dollar chalupa all of a sudden
becomes 750.
no i'm not getting it
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]
you